the human brain develops incredibly
slowly compared to most animals and so
do its cells some neurons can take years
to reach adulthood but what makes them
grow so
slowly these scientists wanted answers
so they mapped out exactly what happens
over the first 100 days of a human
cortical neuron's
life they developed a new technique
which used a chemical trigger to make
stem cells rapidly differentiate into
neurons this allowed them to generate
multiple neurons of roughly the same age
they then tracked their development as
they
grew using fluorescence microscopy they
could see that as the cells matured
their electrical activity increased in
intensity and frequency and they started
to fire in sync with each other and they
looked at subtler changes too to the
cells cytoskeletons metabolic processes
and DNA and one set of changes stood out
a gradual decrease in the levels of
certain markers on certain
genes these were epigenetic marks
chemical changes which can repress the
expression of
genes they work by modifying histones
the molecules which support DNA when
they attach the histones pack together
preventing the DNA from being
expressed that led the team to wonder if
these marks were helping control the
pace of cell development so the
researchers knocked out the genes that
controlled the levels of the relevant
marks and the neurons started maturing
faster the marks were repressing certain
genes associated with cell maturation
acting a bit like a break slowing the
neurons
development over time the level of these
marks gradually decreases which exposes
the DNA and allows it to be expressed
the epigenetic break is lifted and the
neurons can
mature after looking at Mouse neurons
the team think that the same thing might
be happening there only they have fewer
of the epigenetic marks to start off
with and so less of a breaking effect
allowing their neurons to develop much
more
quickly this process of epigenetic
breaking seems to begin even before the
neurons are formed with the markers
already present in the neural stem
cell these new findings could help
researchers artificially speed up the
development of neurons in the lab
instead of having to wait for them to
grow at their natural rate this could be
particularly useful for Research into
conditions like Parkinson's which mainly
affects adult neurons and the team think
it'll help them unpick even more of the
complex systems that control how fast
cells
grow